What did you learn about the nature of politics?
And did this made you into a more optimistic
or more pessimistic human being?
What politics did teach me is that nothing
is impossible.
I grew up in the eastern part of the country,
border of Mozambique.
When the war of liberation started I was a
small boy but I did see the war.
At that time, it was unthinkable that the
guerrillas could defeat this monolithic army,
of people who had helicopters, cars, big cars,
big guns.
But I lived to see the system collapse.
I lived to see the people awakening from a position of disadvantage win.
And then, when I joined the opposition, it
was unthinkable that one day president Mugabe’s
government can be beaten.
I lived to see Mugabe being beaten in 2008.
I lived to see myself actually winning an
election as a member of parliament of course.
But I also saw the brutal side of politics.
Politics without rules is a recipe for disaster
for men and for mankind.
There must be rules and they have necessarily
to be written.
There must be social rules that govern people,
we can be this unfair but not that unfair.
And what I have seen is that most politicians
go all the way to get what they want, inspective
of how they get it.
So, in the world of politics, especially in
the world of politics, I have seen people
treat each other in the most despicable way
of manners.
Mr. Mugabe, still president of your country,
was, if I remember correctly, one of those
freedom fighters to turn Rhodesia into Zimbabwe,
into a free African country.
He became president, he is president for 36
years.
What did you learn about the nature of power?
I am asking you this because our first round
table conversation during the conference 'What
will save the world?' will be about the defect
in society.
Probably, the nature of power has something
to do with it.
George Orwell, in 'Animal farm' was very prophetic.
You would think that he wrote it with Zimbabwe
in mind.
The way the animals fight, win together, get
power, and the way they treat each other when
the power is begotten.
I think mr.
Mugabe was a good fighter for liberation and
he did things well.
Unfortunately, when we got into independence,
he founded the instruments of oppression used
by his predecessors.
He could use them to suppress and he was tempted
to use these instruments.
So what that teaches us about the nature of
power is that you must limit it before a person
gets it.
The second thing is that a
good leader in war time is not necessarily
a good leader in peace time.
Unfortunately, the British had Churchill during
the war and I cannot think a better man motivating
his country to fight well, in a very difficult
war I suppose.
To see that man at the end of that war losing
an election.
I think it was the realization that you can
be good in war time but you are not necessarily
the best person to do the reconstruction of
the country.
I think Zimbabweans in Mugabe they forgot
that.